[Music]
clark county reached a promising
milestone today 70 percent of residents
have at least one dose of the vaccine
and starting tomorrow thousands of
nevadans are now eligible to get their
pfizer coven 19 booster madison
kimbrough live at one of the many
pharmacies who will be taking walk-ins
starting tomorrow madison
we're currently at a walgreens just one
of the many pharmacies around town
offering the pfizer booster when it is
available starting tomorrow so how do
people feel about it and will they take
advantage if eligible
the cdc is recommending that the
following group receive a boosted dose
as at least six months after the second
dose starting tuesday the covet 19
booster will be available to those who
have completed their two dose series of
the pfizer vaccine those eligible must
be 65 years or older i think it's
wonderful since i'm a diabetic and older
i'm
considering getting the third one yeah
those 18 to 64 can get their booster if
they have jobs that put them at risk for
exposure to the coronavirus and those
with underlying conditions like charlene
however she doesn't know if she wants it
i don't know what difference
is it going to make
i don't think there's enough that enough
people have gotten it in order
for me to make a decision on how many
people are benefiting from it while
charlene may be hesitant thousands of
nevadans who received their second dose
of pfizer at least six months ago can
start rolling up their sleeve
as for those in our state that have
gotten their initial vaccine according
to the state health district more than
62 percent of adults have already
completed full vaccination reporting
live madison kimbrough live local now